honey forces in South Sudan's Army have
been told to be loyal to the country and
not to politics individuals or ethnicity
the formation of a military made up of
both former Rebel Fighters and
government troops is underway we have
managed to unify the the top actions of
the command we are yet to complete the
unification of the the middle actually
which is very key because the process is
unification and not integration so
that's why you have to unify it at all
level and before you unify especially at
the top level and the middle level
the senior officers also have to go
through orientation and training
these soldiers form part of the first
batch of graduates many don't have guns
the government says an arms embargo
imposed by the United Nations security
Council in 2018 makes it hard to buy
weapons
delays in implementing the 2018 peace
deal have forced a postponement of the
country's first presidential election
for those elections to take place people
displaced by years of conflict need to
feel safe enough to return home
according to the UN there are more than
2 million internally displaced people in
South Sudan and another 2.3 million have
fled the country as refugees fighting in
some areas continues to kill and
displays large numbers of civilians
the process has been slow it's been slow
the political Elites who have been
dragging their Fates is simply because
there are two principles he's Excellency
president and his Excellence first vice
president if a high deficit in trust and
confidence for working together as a
Partners to deliver the country from
violence to peace
South Sudan's president salvakia has
promised to resume talks with armed
groups that did not sign the 2018 peace
deal that agreement stopped the worst of
the fighting but there are lingering
tensions in communities that possess
many weapons and that will make
maintaining peace and Security even more
difficult for South Sudan's new and
poorly equipped unified National Army
haramutasa Al Jazeera Juba